What advice do you have for those who have weak,
poor,
or otherwise ineffective leaders?
How do you manipulate that situation?
So again,
I think I may have actually answered this question before,
but I'll answer it again.
Sure.
When,
Eh,
when you are in a situation like this,
when you've got somebody that's weak or ineffective leader or a poor leader,
the answer's always the same.
What you do is you lead,
you lead yourself and I hope people that listen to podcast,
all of irregular,
you all knew what I was going to say there.
You all know that when someone is not leading you,
then you lead them.
You pick up the slack for the weakness.
My leaders want to come up with a plan.
Cool.
I will.
My leader doesn't want to give a brief.
That's fine.
I will.
My leader doesn't want to mentor the younger troops.
That's okay.
I will do it.
Leader doesn't want to take the blame when something goes wrong.
That's fine with me.
I'm going to take the blame
and you think about that one.
That one can be tricky because you think I'm going to look bad in front of the,
in front of the more senior boss.
Now think about it from the senior bosses position.
If if you work for me echo and the boss comes in and we the,
the mission was a failure and I'm the,
I'm the guy that's in charge and I say,
sorry boss,
we failed.
It was echo's fault and echo goes,
hey sir,
it was my fault.
Here's what happened,
here's the mistakes I made and here's what to do to fix it next time.
Who Do you respect more?
Yeah,
of course I'm looking to promote you.
You know,
I actually want to promote you and our fire myself from being a guy that's
passing the buck and passing responsibility,
not taking ownership of everything.
So imagine what that looks like before you get all intimidated by taking the
blame for something and think you're going to look bad and think you're going to
get fired.
Think about what it looks like from the senior perspective and you actually have
to imagine what it will look like underneath you.
You have to see it from your perspective cause it's even when you think about
their perspective,
you still can be in fear of it.
You Think,
oh I'm the guy that's taking the blame.
I'm the one that's going to get fired.
No.
And am I saying this like blanket that there's some times where if the boss
screw something up really bad,
like let's say it was something like classified information got left out and it
was your boss that literally left it out and you go,
no,
it was me.
Well first of all,
you're not telling the truth.
Right?
So you're not telling the truth and the person made a mistake.
That's that.
There's no excuse for yeah.
So that's not a situation that I'm talking about.
And if your boss was the type of person that said yes,
I'm going to put the blame on him,
I would burn them alive.
I'd be like,
actually,
here's what really happened.
So
I'm not talking about that type of situation.
But when you're doing an operational thing where there's mistakes that get made
and your to scared to take ownership of them,
take ownership of them,
not that you will win in the long run.
Um,
now the,
now here's the part that is crucial and critical and the most challenging part
of this.
And that is when you step up and lead,
you want to make sure you aren't stepping up and stepping on your leader.
You don't want to step into their little spotlight.
You don't want to impose yourself in their leadership limelight.
And Gloria,
you don't want to do that.
You,
you,
you can't do that.
You want them to get the credit.
You don't want to have them be intimidated by you in any way.
And this is hard because when you start taking ownership for stuff,
it's very,
it can be very intimidating for the person that's above you because they think,
Dang,
this guy just,
he's just a bold bastard than stepping up and taking charge of stuff.
And they might get intimidated that.
So,
so what you have to do is you have to do some,
some indirect maneuver warfare here.
And for instance,
if they don't want to,
if they don't want to come up with a plan,
maybe you start saying,
hey sir,
what do you think of this?
Would this be a good plan?
And maybe if you're,
if they're not mentoring the younger guys,
maybe you say,
Hey,
you know what?
I want to do this up.
I want to spend some time with the guys after work.
Do you mind if I have a little session with them?
Kind of go over what we learned on last appointment or hey,
about this new regulatory thing that's come out in the business world and I want
to get our younger troops to know it.
Do you mind if I teach a class on that?
So you're,
you're asking them permission and you might even say,
you know,
hey,
I think it would look really good for you too if we were doing this.
Do you want to make them look good?
Um,
and
those are the ways that you do that.
You step up and lead.
But make sure you're not stepping on your leader because that,
that that could backfire and you could end up in a situation where they feel
intimidated and you're getting put in the dog house or fired or demoted or in
trouble because they feel intimidated by you.
So use caution if you have a good leader.
Some leaders just aren't that aggressive and when you start getting aggressive
they start,
they actually like the fact that you're getting aggressive and they like,
I mean I work for some people that I love the fact that I would take a step up
and take charge.
They had no problem with it because they were good confident leaders.
It's the insecure leader you have to watch out for the insecure leader that's
worried about looking bad and that's another two to change perspective.
Again on this,
when you as a leader have somebody that's stepping up and taking charge as and
you start feeling intimidated by it,
ask yourself why.
It's probably your ego.
You're being a weak leader by being intimidated by your subordinates.
If your subordinate is doing your job at doing it better than you let get step
up and start looking at how can you go up the chain of command?
How can you look up and out?
How,
what other areas can you focus on?
Since that leader has stepped up and is making things happen,
that's awesome.
That is awesome.
We want that [inaudible].
That's decentralized command,
that's building other leaders underneath you,
which is what your goal is.
A leader should always be,
and I'll tell you,
every time I see someone that goes,
oh,
I got a weak leader.
I'm always like,
lucky you.
Lucky you.
Take advantage of that.
Take advantage of it.
Do whatever you want.
You have such a good opportunity when you have a weak leader above,
you don't look at that.
Don't,
don't get all down trodden because one leader just doesn't motivate you.
Awesome.
Motivate yourself,
get char,
get in charge of things,
take advantage of it.
Make things happen.
It's awesome to have a weak leader.
I love it.
Get after it.
It's good to give me so much mobility in my,
in my,
in my job.
Right?
I'm so much more mobility than if I've got someone,
Hey,
if I've got someone that's a strong leader,
that's great too.
But weak leaders know factor.
Hmm.
I'm gonna take advantage of it.
Yes,
yes.
I would
like you got a weak leader and,
and you're,
um,
you're not stepping up.
You're essentially allowing the,
the group,
the team,
the objectives to kind of fail in a way.
You're kind of allowing it and then in a way to depends on what you do,
but in a way you're kind of be being like,
Hey,
all right.
You're allowing the excuse to be valid.
You know,
where,
which kind of makes it invalid really,
when you're like,
Hey,
I could step up,
but hey,
it's the leaders for as long as it's not my fault.
You know,
that my leaders,
not that it's you really not taking much ownership.
Yeah.
You just point your finger at your leader and say,
this is a weak leader.
That's not what we do here.
Not what we do at all.
And at the Times where I've had weak leaders,
I always took advantage of it.
Like I said one time,
and I've talked about this on the podcast before we fired our leader.
No,
we had a little mutiny that only happened once for me.
But yeah,
it happens that,
I mean,
I obviously,
I don't know all the details of that,
but in a way isn't that you just stepping up and making it happen.
I mean,
that's really the basic impending result.
Like Dang,
that's,
that's kind of where we're going to arrive at freely given us stepping up.
If,
if that's how it goes down.
That's how it goes down.
But you stepped up,
you solve the problem,
they're the problem,
and that was the problem.
There's your solution.
Yes.
Up and down the chain of command.
You got to own it for sure.